MALE SPEAKER: OK.
We'll get started
now with session two.
We have session two
on layout performance.
And to moderate this session, we
have Mike Shaver from Facebook.
Mike, take it away.
MIKE SHAVER: Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
Excited to be here.
So I'll tell you a little
bit about the panelists here,
and then we'll get started.
Charles works on,
at Flipboard, living
the adventure of
layout performance
in many different browsers.
Wilson, developer in Firefox
OS and author of Library Fast
DOM, which gets good
performance by avoiding
the overhead of actually
laying things out.
Christopher Chedeau, on
the React team at Facebook,
who-- he provides a library
that gets good performance
by avoiding touching the DOM.
David Baron, who works
[INAUDIBLE] at Mozilla,
trying to give us fewer reasons
to avoid layout and touching
layout in the DOM.
And Paul Lewis,
developer advocate
who tries to help developers
make their applications quick,
using all the power of the web
and in spite, in some cases,
of the power of the web.
And Paul will get us started
with a quick presentation
here about layout performance.
PAUL LEWIS: Great.
So what I'm going to
do is to just start
talking about what layout
is just so we framed
the conversation a little bit.
The layout's the process of
converting the DOM styles
to a geometric
representation of the page.
So it's about getting data
concerning width, height,
location, and visibility
of every element.
And for the initial
load-- so we sort of think
of this as the first
frame-- you need
to know everything about every
element and its geometry.
So you kind of calculate
the world, right?
But for subsequent
frames, you might only
change part of the
page, like, I don't
know, adding more
information to something,
expanding something, maybe
even removing something.
And hopefully, we'd only
calculate the layout
for that smaller part of the
tree, or you'd think anyway.
But actually, most
of the time, layout
is scoped to the
entire document.
And this is sort
of in large part
due to the web's layout
model, the document flow
that we're all used to.
If you change the width
of body, then most likely,
everything inside of
that's going to change.
And if you change something
further down the tree,
then [INAUDIBLE]
all the way back up
will at least get checked.
And if they're effective, then
they may get laid out as well.
But layout is kind of one
part of this whole pipeline.
And this being a kind of
simplified version, which
includes JavaScript, and
includes style calculations,
painting, and composition.
And layout itself is sort of
borne of CSS, kind of sadly,
I think, in some ways, with the
classic box model, flex grid,
all these things that
we've had over time.
Other things about layout.
You can't trigger layout
without also triggering paint,
because as you
change the geometry,
you'll need to change pixels.
So for most cases, today
when you trigger layout
and therefore paint, you'll
probably miss frames.
So we basically tell you
to avoid it at all costs.
Or if you're going to do it,
do it judiciously so the user
doesn't notice.
So essentially, we've
ended up with this kind
of fairly intricate relationship
with the parts about pages.
And from a layout
point of view at least,
it's a finely balanced
house of cards.
We fight with CSS,
we fight with layout,
both to get good performance
but to avoid brittleness.
From the outside,
I think layout is
really difficult
to reason about.
If I change the height of
this element over here,
what happens inside
the layout engine?
I don't know.
I have no idea, not a clue.
Try it, and find out.
It's exciting, right?
And how long should I expect
that to take on, like,
a Nexus 5?
I don't know.
And what about all the browsers?
You might get something from
Chrome, but you might not.
And even then, you've still
got all these other browsers
to deal with.
So we don't always
get the insight
that I think we probably
need to make good decisions.
So from a developer
point of view,
I think it's just
difficult to understand
what's going on in
the pipeline and what
the impact of your
code is going to be.
So I think that's why, for me,
this panel is really important.
Because for anybody who's
serious about building
for the web, fast loading and
fast-running pages are crucial,
especially those things
like service worker kick-in
and loading changes-- then the
differentiator might actually
be how people feel
about your app
when they're actually
using the thing.
Because what we're
trying to avoid
is that judder of
missed frames or worse,
a complete halt,
because we know it's
going to kill the
user experience.
That's the thing
we want to avoid.
And for me, I think layout
performance is actually a proxy
for, I want my
stuff to run well,
because right now
it probably doesn't.
Not necessarily layout
itself is that little task
in the pipeline.
So broadening our view a little
bit then, we and our users
want fast-running
experiences, and we're
sad when we don't get them.
But I wanna kind of ask,
whose problem is that?
Allow me to present
two extremes of views
to that particular question.
First of all, it's entirely
the browser manufacturer's
responsibility.
I should just write
my code, and they
should make sure
that it runs well.
For me, that would be like
telling a car manufacturer
that you expect to be
able to get to 60 miles
an hour no matter what fuel
you put in, how you drive,
or what you end up carrying.
Just seems on the touch
unreasonable side to me, that.
On the other extreme,
it's entirely
the developer's responsibility.
Things can perform well.
They can go fast as long as they
don't trigger layouts or paint.
And that, for me, is like the
car manufacturer, in response,
telling you you can only change
gears at exactly 4,000 RPM.
And for the love of
all that is decent,
we know we've given
you a steering wheel,
but please don't turn left,
because the car will explode.
So I'm not convinced that that's
actually the right question
to ask-- who's going
to make this faster?
I think a better
question to ask is,
do we even have
the right pipeline,
and is it optimized
for the right thing?
So to answer that
one, I think we're
going to do a little bit
of armchair philosophy,
a sort of philosophy of web
development, if you like,
to ask the important
questions like,
what experiences are
we trying to make,
what's the difference between
a web app and a website?
And if text is invented by
minus 999 EMs and nobody's
about to read it,
is it truly there?
Let's start with
the big one, the one
that actually I
think matters today.
What experiences are we
actually trying to make?
Or put another way, what's the
primary use case of the web?
Because that, for me, should
define our path, the questions
we ask ourselves and crucially,
what we optimize for.
For context, Android
and, of course, iOS
as well, both have a very clear,
single use case for me-- apps.
Everything is in support of
apps and very little else.
We, on the other
hand, have a platform
that's grown out of documents,
that's its origins, right?
Headings, sections, articles,
the document object model.
And we have sort of fairly funny
layout models in some places.
But as we try and
make web apps, we've
realized there's a bit
of a mismatch here.
We don't have, included
in our platform,
app-like primitives like
infinite scrolling list views,
or master detail
views, and navigation
draws, or pull to refresh, or
all the other things that we've
heard from that first panel.
Actually, you can build
something like those,
but it requires
significant work often
at the cost of circumventing
the browser's models
or reimplementing things
like scrolling yourself.
To my mind, we've
got a few options.
In ascending order
of extremity, one,
we can keep improving
the web-- add a rocket
to the back of the
car in the hope
that our entire
pipeline will eventually
become fast enough for us
to do what it is we want.
And the good news
there is that there
are significant improvements
happening in all the browsers.
Streamlining a
style calculations,
layout itself, GP
rasterization, or fixes
to touch input latency.
But is that enough?
Is that going to get us there?
Two, we could keep
polishing but add
in new hooks and new
primitives to better equip
the pipeline for
web apps, assuming
that's what we want to do.
What about hooks into
the layout engine
that let you decide what
gets laid out when and how.
Or if you want something, some
kind of progressive layout
or something like
that, sort of lo-fi,
hi-fi, what do we do to
the pipeline that gives you
that power?
For me, the extensible web
manifesto is a good thing,
but for some reason,
rendering seemd
to get a pass in
that conversation.
And it's not something
that's being extended yet.
And I think it makes the system
more able to reason about
if you get those
controls, hopefully.
And it's just less magic.
But if we still want
magic, we could always
fork the web, which
is not necessarily
what I think we want to do.
But we could explicitly
create, like,
a web app-centric fast path and
aggressively deprecate anything
that just stands in our way.
Why not?
It's the future.
I think that would
be sad for the web.
I actually do.
And I think we don't want
to see it bifurcated.
I'm not convinced
we need it either.
But in the interests
of completeness,
there you have the third option.
Ultimately, though,
I think those
are technical
considerations, and we
might do a balance
of all those three.
For me, they have to subordinate
to the primary question.
We have a layout pipeline.
It is phenomenally successful
at laying out documents,
but we're trying to make
it amazing for web apps.
And when push comes to shove,
if we can't have an engine that
is amazing or even good at
both, what do we actually want?
What do we want our engines
to be default-fast for?
Lots of questions and
perhaps not many answers.
But then that's the job
of the panel, isn't it?
So I guess with that,
I'll say thanks,
and suggest we get started.
MIKE SHAVER: Thank you, Paul.
[APPLAUSE]
Waiting for my on slide, make
sure I get the right question.
Pretty sure I know what
the first question is.
So following on to
that, I mean, one
of the big gaps we
have in the performance
landscape for the web is the
lack of a layout benchmark.
We have them for
scripting, we have them
for compositing, and
canvas, and various pieces
of network activity.
We really don't
have one for layout.
I think that makes
it under-represented
in the performance
work that happens.
So I'd like to ask you,
Charles-- you're in this stuff
all the time.
What would you put in the
layout benchmark today?
CHARLES YING: Oh, boy.
Well, put all of Flipboard in
there, and then call it a day.
No.
I mean, there's so many
different types of apps,
but you really want
to get representations
of each of the big apps.
I would say text
rendering is one of them.
We do all sorts of text
measurement and things
like that-- something that
looks like a game, something
that looks like a lot of data.
I mean, we could go anywhere
from consumer to scientific.
It's a broad-- I would say I
don't know the full answer.
I don't know if you can
actually put everything
into a layout benchmark.
MIKE SHAVER: So
actually, and I want
to add just a quick note for
participants from the audience.
If you raise your hand, we
can bring a microphone to you
when you sort of register
yourself to speak there.
And then you'll
have a microphone.
You'll be able to speak.
So I guess actually
while we're waiting
for that to get settled, I'll
throw it over to Paul here.
You're an advocate
for developers.
Benchmarks are a very
effective way for developers
to advocate for themselves.
PAUL LEWIS: They can be.
MIKE SHAVER: Why
don't we have one?
PAUL LEWIS: I worry about
benchmarks getting gamed,
generally.
But that, notwithstanding,
I think, yes.
One of the hard
things is measuring
smoothness is really
difficult today
in a cross browser-- there's no
API that says, is this smooth?
And a couple of days
ago, a Chrome engineer
posted to the Web
Performance group, saying,
we think we could
do with this API.
And I would love to see how
that conversation turns out.
Because if you have
that API, then you
can start making meaningful
benchmarks, hopefully.
And I think you're right.
Like, something that
is representative
of the kind of things that
people are trying to make,
not necessarily the things
they've made in the past,
but what are we
trying to make now?
Like, infinite scrolling
list views or all the stuff
that you guys are
doing at Flipboard.
Let's put that in
there, and let's see
how fast we can get it on
mobile, on desktop, everywhere.
That would be great.
MIKE SHAVER: Uh, Jonathan,
do you have a microphone?
JONATHAN: [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE SHAVER: Oh, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
MIKE SHAVER: Wait.
I'm going to make you
say something anyway.
No, it's fine.
No?
JONATHAN: No.
MIKE SHAVER: Oh, OK.
Next time.
So it's true we don't have the
smoothness there-- smoothness
test, rather.
Is that really a limit?
David, you work on
layout performance.
How do you tell if
stuff got better
if you don't have
a smoothness API?
Can we not measure
layout in some other way?
DAVID BARON: I don't know.
A lot of the measuring we do
is still about absolute time,
I think.
When we're actually
looking at layout itself
as a very narrow thing.
We are starting to have tools
internally for measuring
things like frame
rate and so on.
I think the conversation about
how we expose those to the web
is a good one, and
we should have that.
PAUL LEWIS: Certainly, from
Chrome's point of view,
you can load Chrome
as a bunch of flags.
And we use then an
extra API that we
use in telemetry, which
is how we sort of run
through our benchmarks
and go, was that faster?
Was that slower?
And it's all automated.
I think it is this
question of, how
then do you make
that something that's
more broadly available
in a safe way and so on?
And in the right way,
and make it a primitive
that people can build on top of.
Rather than saying we need
necessarily a layout benchmark,
I think it is the right thing to
give the underlying primitive--
this is kind of the
extensible web stuff, right?
And just give them--
and then people
can build the right
things, because it's
very difficult from
the outside to go,
well, we should make a benchmark
that does exactly this one
thing, or we should
make this one case fast,
because like I said,
there's such a range.
And you just end
up making this--
we did this with
scrolling, didn't we?
We made scrolling fast, and
then all of a sudden, people
tried to go off piste.
And it was like, yeah,
that's not going to work.
You don't get scroll events.
That's not going
to play out nicely.
And I kind of feel
like that with anything
that would be-- the
smoothness benchmark,
you've got to just kind of take
a step back and say, what do we
need to give developers so
that they can start testing it
themselves in the way that makes
sense for their applications?
WILSON PAGE: For load time,
we have the page speed score.
Could we have
something like that,
like sort of gamifiy
the whole thing,
and have people go, I've got
a layout time of this much,
like collapsing that,
having something
[INAUDIBLE] the same way.
You collapse the whole
page, open it up,
and you've got a score,
like, from nothing
to this much is how much your
page takes to layout, paint,
everything.
And you could get,
say, we reckon
that's a pretty good score, we
reckon that's an awful score.
Your DOM's too big,
or the kind of things
you're positioning
it too complex.
Is that something we can
do, so people can clearly
identify when their page is
good and when their page is bad?
PAUL LEWIS: I would love that.
I think the score is like a
really good first indicator of,
is it good or is it bad?
Hopefully, you'd be able
to see that from this thing
not working nicely.
But beyond that,
it's like, if you've
got something that's
not playing nicely--
we were talking about
this last night.
If you've got three things
that aren't playing nicely
and you remove one,
and all of a sudden,
it looks like it's
playing more nicely,
you don't necessarily know
what it was that one thing.
It could have been three things
that weren't playing nicely
together, and you removed the
one that broke the condition.
But you want more
information, not just a score,
not just a number at the end.
You want to kind of know, how
did you arrive at that answer,
so that I can make more
intelligent guesses, rather
than this big, black
box of, hey, you
put some CSS and some DOM in.
You get a number out the other
side or a frames per second.
Like, let people sort of
start to dive into that.
It's probably a bit
overwhelming, though.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: Yeah.
I think you need some
dev tools, you know,
to make it easier
for the developer
to know what's going on.
So for example, like, if you're
looking at a news feed perf,
you're going to say,
oh, I changed this,
so I trigger the
re-flow or layout.
And now what?
So you have a timing, but you
have no idea what happened
and where you should be
organize your code to be faster
or what happened in layout,
which elements were layout.
And so we don't have
this information.
So we have to guess and
try to test something.
But it's like, yeah, as you
said, a real black box for us.
CHARLES YING: When
we profile our app,
we frequently see hot spots
being spent either in painting,
or in layout, or in [INAUDIBLE]
coding, or in compositing.
And they trade places
all in the same profile.
I mean, it would be great
if everything was integrated
together and you can see,
like, oh, JPEG decoding
was taking this
long, or the gradient
draw that I was doing
is taking this long.
We have that on native side.
When we profile our
JavaScript apps,
it says, well, paint
took this long,
and layout took this long.
And you're like,
where do I start?
DAVID BARON: Yeah.
Some of those conditions are
very complicated, though,
because you end
up in a situation
where you've done something
that makes the painting process
itself slow, you've
done something else
that makes you paint a lot.
Fixing either one of those would
fix your performance problem.
And we need to
somehow figure out
how to show that information
to you in a useful way.
And that's kind of hard.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I agree.
I was profiling
something this past week.
And there were, like,
1,000 or so elements.
And they all had
Overflow Hidden on.
And layout was
actually really fast.
Generally speaking, layout's
But layer management is not.
Or it's getting better,
but it wasn't in this case.
And the thing was I
turned off Overflow Hidden
as a bit of a guess.
I was like, I wonder what
happens if I do this.
And sure enough, layer
management went down,
but layout went
through the roof.
It went from 9 milliseconds
up to 77 milliseconds.
Looking at this, I was
like, I don't know why.
I have to speak to our
engineers, who very kindly sit
with me and explain, in simple
terms, why this is true.
But as a developer, you
look at this, you go,
I just changed one style.
Everything went really weird.
Now what do I do?
And that's the problem I
desperately want us to solve.
Like, how do we make
that reasonable again?
MIKE SHAVER: Absolutely.
Something here from
Steve [INAUDIBLE].
STEVE: In the world of
performance metrics,
we have these kind of two
camps of synthetic and ROM
where ROM is real user traffic.
And a lot of the things that I
feel have been talked about so
far is on the
synthetic side, we're
collecting profiles on
heavily instrumented browsers
in the dev world or in a lab.
And I haven't heard
people talking
about metrics that could be
gathered on real traffic.
And there was that great
blog post like a year or so
ago from Twitter
where they said,
our performance metric
is time to first tweet.
But I forget exactly
what they did.
But whatever they
did really wasn't
exactly on when the
tweet was rendered,
because we have no way of
measuring that via JavaScript
on real pages.
And so it seems like we
could do a lot of things
on what kind of
rendering metrics
we want to gather in the
real world, but like,
this is a really obvious one.
I've got a key
container in my page
that contains the first
tweet or the photo of the day
or whatever, and I
just want to know
when it finishes rendering.
Is there a way that we--
are people working on that?
Or what kind of
real-world metrics
can be gathered with
regard to layout?
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: So
what we do on the iOS app
is we log for each
news feed cell
how much time it
takes to run them.
And so this way, we
know on each device
all the devices, how
much time [INAUDIBLE],
so we can improve it.
And we also have
a smoothness test
where we log how many FPS
do we get, how many frames
do we drop, when do we drop
them, what causes a drop.
And this way, we can
aggregate on the real traffic
how much layouts is costing
us and how much rendering
is costing us.
But unfortunately,
on the web, there's
no real API for us to do that.
MIKE SHAVER: OK.
Great.
So I think we'll move to
the next question now.
Excellent.
We'll move to the
next question now.
So most of the performance
improvements that we see today
are really being focused
around GPU optimization,
especially around rasterization
and compositing it,
making that asynchronous or
doing it in alternate hardware.
Once that well was
dry, or to apply
to other aspects of
layout performance,
where do we see the next major
performance improvement there?
And I'll ask, I
guess, David to start.
What's on the menu?
DAVID BARON: In some ways,
it's hard to predict.
One area that could
be big is parallelism
just because one of the
trends with hardware
these days is that you're
not getting faster cores,
you're getting more cores.
And the web needs to figure
out how to exploit that better.
Things like script in
the DOM-- like the web
sort of has the sort of
single-threaded programming
model of the DOM.
But there are things
in layout that
can certainly be
parallelized better.
That said, we don't
even necessarily
know what the next
thing is going to be.
It could end up being other
things that make things faster.
PAUL LEWIS: When I
tested it this past week,
and I have spoken with people,
layout itself was fast.
And parallelizing that
doesn't seem to me
to bring us any great wins
unless I'm missing something
from there.
I agree, though.
We definitely-- the
thing we optimized
for is what I was trying
to say at the start
is we have to optimize
in the direction
that people want us to go, which
is if you're trying to build
web apps, we should try
and make web apps fast.
It's probably a really simple
way to look at the world.
CHARLES YING: Another
way to improve speed
is to reduce the amount
of work that's being done.
I mean, we have
parallel core desktops,
but when you look
at a mobile phone,
we're still at quad core,
which still blows my mind.
But small numbers
of cores on phones.
So one way to do
that would be to give
fast paths or different ways
of having web apps interact
with the browser core.
For example, the way
React does a virtual DOM,
and batches commands, and sends
them to the DOM all at once.
And that is an improved
API if you had some deeper
integration, so the browser
could understand those things.
And apps are not
integrating so much.
PAUL LEWIS: The
thing that worries me
about that is this idea that
you have to take everything off.
It's like reimplementing
the browser's everything
to just do the one thing.
And that just feels so alien.
Like you say, if the deeper
integration is these hooks
in so that you actually
have more direct control
over the parts of the pipeline
rather than having to go,
I'll just do it all
myself then, fine,
if you want a job done properly.
CHARLES YING: Well, I
think it's more of, like,
batching up things.
So for example, the way I said
attributes on a DOM element
is I have to call-- if I
want to set 10 attributes,
I have to say, set attribute,
set attribute, set attribute.
Or I could inject
HTML, which I don't
know if that's even better.
But if there was a command that
said, like, send 10 attributes
and set them all at once
as one call, for example.
Some kind of improved APIs.
MALE SPEAKER:
Could we get more--
MIKE SHAVER: Sorry, I'm going
to take one from the delegates
there, too.
Oh, I was going to.
Was it Jordan?
No.
MALE SPEAKER: It's
different [INAUDIBLE].
MIKE SHAVER: It's different now.
Ada?
Does Ada have a microphone?
Oh.
Oh, gees.
Sorry.
Sorry, I thought we
had somebody up there.
AUDIENCE: Is it worth having
multiple optimized settings
that you could say, this
page is more like a web app,
this page is more like a
document, optimize accordingly?
MIKE SHAVER: Yeah.
Well, I think it'd be an
interesting question maybe
for David is, what could
developers tell you
about their pages that would let
you lay them out more quickly,
let you render
them more quickly.
DAVID BARON: I think
whenever there's a-- no, no,
that's too strong a statement.
But there are many cases
where there's things
that developers could
tell us that we could
use to optimize in one
direction or another.
But we could also just do
those things on our own.
We can detect that you
don't use this feature
and optimize that way.
The hard part about
that is the risk
is we create weird
performance characteristics
for the platform.
In other words, if we
have a mechanism where
if you don't use any floats,
some set of layout things
are a lot faster.
And then you pull in some
piece of external content
that has a float, and
you trigger that bit.
That's going to
be hard to debug.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: But
the storage is the case.
DAVID BARON: Yeah.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: If you
have on-wheel and you use it,
then you're going to
hit all the [INAUDIBLE]
performance in WebKit.
MIKE SHAVER: Yeah.
OK.
I want to take-- Larry
was up and then not.
And now here he is.
Yes, I want to take a
question from him [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to ask
you to talk about the
relationship of relay
out performance in the
HTTP2 with server push
and prioritization,
because I thought
that would be a major factor of
something new coming that would
change how layout would perform.
DAVID BARON: I think there
are a bunch of things
we can do to get better-- like,
provide feedback from layout
within the browser to
better prioritize what
resources we're loading.
I think hopefully,
some of that will
be happening within not
too far in the future.
But that's not something--
I wouldn't expect things
like orders of magnitude
improvement out of that.
But I would expect sort
of better responsiveness
for the first useful
appearance of a page.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU:
So I have a question.
So on iOS, what we do is
we render all the stories,
like, in a different thread.
And whenever they are rendered,
we push into the main thread.
And unfortunately, we
cannot do that on the web,
because in a web [INAUDIBLE]
we cannot have access to CSS.
And we cannot even-- like, I
tried to re-implement a big
part of CSS, but I don't have
any text measurement API.
So I cannot even
re-implement CSS.
So is there a way
for me as a developer
to prepare some of the part of
the UI in a different thread,
and then push them back to the
main thread, so we don't stall?
MIKE SHAVER: That
actually takes us--
I think, actually,
this is, I think,
a good opportunity to move
to the next question, which
is pretty related.
Actually, I'll
take Dominic first.
And then I want to come back
to this topic, because it's
where we end up with
the next question.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I guess my question--
MIKE SHAVER: Can you
please stand up-- sorry--
so the camera can get you?
AUDIENCE: Hi, camera.
Oh, OK.
MIKE SHAVER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: My question
is what can we
learn from other operating
systems and native app
frameworks and so on?
Like, what is the web doing
that's so different that makes
it so hard, or is it hard
everywhere and everybody's
just more professional
on iOS and they're
able to do their job and
get 60 frames per second
and we're not?
Like, what is different
in iOS and Windows and all
these things that
we could learn from?
MIKE SHAVER: Yeah.
And we actually have a question
to that that I do wanna
sort of get to, but
I'd sort of like to-- I
think that's a bigger
question than we have time
for in the remaining
time on this topic.
I want to make sure we have
a bunch of time for it.
But I do want to
push in here-- there
was another sort of question.
So we can move to
the next one here.
Layout's often poorly
suited, as Christopher
was saying, to having innovation
in user space, in script space.
It's hard to poly-fill new
layout types and so forth.
What do libraries
need from browsers?
What are the most
important primitives
to expose there, so
we could see more
of these things experimented
on at the pace of the script
library rather than at the
pace of browser implementation?
WILSON PAGE: Well, I think
I'd be really excited just
to have more hooks,
like Paul was saying,
into when the browser
is doing things.
Like we have
requestanimationframe,
which is great to do just
before paint, so we can be like,
yep, get that at the right time.
But it'd be really
interesting to know even
when layout has happened or
when layout is about to happen,
because sometimes parts
of the page might change,
and you just have no idea.
There's no way of detecting when
the parts of the page change,
because if you were doing
stuff in JavaScript,
some things in layout
that CSS can't do,
you need to be able to know,
ah, a class in the body
changed which hid
this thing, and then
changed the width of this.
And you just have
no way of knowing--
mutation observers
don't go that far.
So that's something
I think would really
enable libraries to do more.
MIKE SHAVER: And Alex?
To Christophers' point--
I wish my colleague,
Elliott's friend was here.
He'd do a much
better job of this.
Oh, is he?
Well, Elliott,
how about you take
this about what the
primitives for CSS should be.
MALE SPEAKER: Here
you go, Elliott.
MIKE SHAVER: That
was beautifully done.
ELLIOTT: I got
microphone-sniped.
I think the biggest thing
that's missing right now
is text measurement,
as brought up.
We have no API to measure text.
And that's usually deficient.
And Canvas has this really
painful to use text measurement
API.
Anyone who's ever used
it understands quite
how painful it is.
And I think if I was going to
expand the space right now,
I would like to expose the way
that we break up line boxes,
and wrap text, and measure
text, and text justification,
and glyph sizing.
And I think that
that goes a long way.
Canvas already has the
ability to draw a rectangle,
but it has no way to wrap text.
And that just seems
like something
that we should solve for you.
WILSON PAGE: Yeah, the
case I was talking about
was actually a component we
made where we had to, like,
dynamically fit text in a box.
Like the box is this big.
OK, let's shrink the text
down, and like, oh-- just
using the available space.
And we had to do
some measurements,
and there might be
pieces either side
of the text which
change the block size.
Or those pieces
might get hidden.
And it's really hard
for us to detect that.
So sometimes we just have
to manually say, resize now.
And I don't know.
It gets messy.
It gets really messy.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: So to
get back on W's question,
the way the browser layout
works is you put your CSS,
and the browser is going to do
an entire layout [INAUDIBLE]
on everything.
And if you want to
control the [INAUDIBLE]
for the one element, you want
to inside change what you want,
like to change the size
of the inner element,
you've got to do a full
layout pass, measured element,
update the children, and
do a full layout pass.
And the way it's working
on iOS and on Android
is for each element,
you know its size,
and you have to manually
specify the size of the children
and the size of yourself.
So the API is a
lot more painful,
but it enables you to do, like,
everything you want, basically.
So on one side on
web, it's pretty easy.
You declare what you
want, and it gets done.
But you don't have that
fine-grained control.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
And the web, in that
sense, becomes magical.
And it's brilliant, because if
you just want to lay out text,
it will do it for you.
But if you want to take
control and do that yourself,
there is no way, right?
And this is firmly--
I'll be interested to see
how the extensible web
one goes this afternoon,
because I think that's
right in that territory of,
can you expose these
things in such a way
that if somebody was desperate
to do their own text layout,
they could do that,
and they could also
measure how long
that thing took?
Because that's the
other aspect to this.
You can go off-road,
do your own thing.
But you should also
know the impact
of doing that and what
you're trading off
when you take the browser's
job from it and do it yourself.
What does that actually then
mean for you and your app?
CHARLES YING: At
Flipboard, we actually do
a lot of our page
layout in JavaScript.
And that's because
we want things
like baseline grids, and
column grids, and gutters,
and things that just
aren't available
in the browser, something
like CSS columns,
but with more
things that we want
specific to our application.
And we struggle with
things like knowing
when the font loaded
so we could measure it.
And we have workarounds
to measure text.
And we get around
it by saying, let's
put a DOM element into the
body, and size it this way,
and then measure it.
But that's really hacky.
And we still don't know
when the font loaded.
So those are the kinds of
things that we deal with.
And it's top of
the profile for us.
Everything else, we
can kind of get done.
But not that.
DAVID BARON: I think
Elliott's point
about exposing the stuff
about text measurement,
and breaking, and
wrapping, and things
like that, I hadn't actually
heard that feedback before.
And it's certainly
something useful
that I think is relatively
doable in terms of something
we can expose.
I think it's also somewhat
different from the idea
of actually exposing
the full layout
model in the idea behind the
extensible web manifesto, which
would sort of say that we
want to actually expose
the concepts you would need to
do something like build Flexbox
in an implementation that
didn't already have it.
That said, doing all of
that is really hard because
of the complexity of
all the existing layout
concepts that we have,
and how those concepts
interact with each other in a
whole bunch of different ways.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: So yeah.
To get back on you on the
trying to re-implement Flexbox,
one of the big missing parts we
have is you cannot [INAUDIBLE]
it, because if you add a
rule that doesn't exist
in the browser, the browser--
like, in the dev tools,
you can see it,
but in JavaScript,
you have no way to
actually see it.
So one of the great things
with browser and JavaScript
is you can poly-fill all
the APIs back to IE6.
But in the CSS, you cannot.
And the people that did
poly-fill Flexbox, what
they did, they implemented
a full CSS parser
and a full, like,
CSS selector engine.
And every time something
changes in the DOM,
they re-implement CSS.
And just you get
Flexbox, which is crazy.
DAVID BARON: I think that's
the easy part, though.
Like, I think we could add--
MIKE SHAVER: I think
that's very telling
that that's the easy part.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAVID BARON: Well, no.
I think fixing that is the
easy part in that we could
add an API for poly-filling
CSS properties.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: Please do.
DAVID BARON: And
that would be an API.
But that API would be much
easier to add than the API
for becoming part
of a layout model.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: Yeah.
Well, that's the first step.
MIKE SHAVER: And Alex?
Oh.
Sorry, yeah.
When you have a comment,
to raise your hand up.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
So my question is, are
we going to a future
where basically the [INAUDIBLE]
going to be exposed?
What should be
exposed to content
alters and what should not?
Because from my
understanding, most content
alters, they [INAUDIBLE]
as a black box.
Like, I write a CSS rule,
and something happens.
MIKE SHAVER: Yeah.
This is an interesting
sort of issue
is how much does it change
the ergonomics of building
a website that just works
across devices and so forth?
What do you think we
shouldn't expose, Paul?
PAUL LEWIS: That's a really--
I don't know what the use case.
Actually, I don't know
what it is at this point
that people are trying
to make-- well, we know.
They're trying to
poly-fill Flexbox.
And it should be in
support of use cases.
It should absolutely be we
are trying to do these things.
What primitives do
we need to do that?
I don't know what those
are at this stage.
I think we just need to
have the conversation rather
than-- getting to this point,
as I said-- rendering today has
had a pass to not
be part, seemingly,
of the extensible web manifesto.
I think that's time that we
took that question, said,
should this actually be exposed?
That's the thing,
the first question.
If the answer's
yes, then I think
we need to have a very long
and probably interesting
conversation about
exactly what, but I
don't know what that is yet.
MIKE SHAVER: I want to
go to Alex in one sec,
but I do want to hear
very quickly from David.
What is the scariest
thing for you
to expose to content authors?
What would you want
to fix right away?
DAVID BARON: It's
hard to even know,
but there's a lot of things in
layout that are pretty scary.
MIKE SHAVER: I'll let you get
away with that only because I
really want to hear from Alex.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
David, I'm really
actually kind of
shocked to hear you say
that you haven't heard
that feedback
before, specifically
because I think the folks
who have been working
in and around the extensible
web manifesto principles
for the last couple of years
have been focused on the idea
that you need to explain
yourself at a platform level
when you provide capabilities
at the high level.
And specifically, text
rendering seems like an easy one
and participating in the
entire area of layout
seems like the obvious
next set of steps for this.
And I think to the
earlier question,
should we expose the
render tree, well,
if we can get a portable
description of how browsers
operate, we owe it to users
to express as much of it
as is safe, right?
The answer of what
shouldn't you expose
is maybe cross-origin
imagery back in a case
where it isn't a core's image.
Those are the sorts
of areas where
there are security
implications for some
of these compositional features
of the web that we can't break.
But in every other area, I
challenge you differently
and suggest that we should
be exposing everything
that the browser can do to
the extent that is possible.
DAVID BARON: I kind of have two
different responses to that.
But I think there are
a few ways where layout
is a little bit different in
that a bunch of the technology
behind style and layout was
sort of designed with things
like device
independence, and being
able to adapt to different
sorts of devices,
being able to adapt to
different user preferences
as sort of a fundamental
characteristic
of those technologies.
I think if we had had these
capabilities before the iPhone,
the iPhone people
would have done
things that would have made
it a lot harder for the iPhone
to adapt to desktop
web content to mobile.
So I think I'm not saying
we shouldn't do it,
but I'm saying I think we need
to be careful and try and do it
in a way that doesn't break
those aspects of the way
these technologies are designed.
MIKE SHAVER: Very quickly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
don't accept your argument,
because the same
is said for DOM.
So for instance, the
argument is that if we
had exposed what it means to
participate in the form system
to the extent that you could
create a custom element, which
is a true input box, then
iOS couldn't have styled
the select element
the way it did.
This is both misdirection
and roughly untrue.
It is the case today
that people already
have very large
JavaScript frameworks
that re-implement large
portions of this stuff.
And that content,
yes, didn't port.
But developers have
strong incentives
to do the things that are
cheap and free in the platform.
And those are the things
that we can adapt.
But it's when developers
get stuck that they
need the flexibility.
And they're not asking
for it because they
don't want you to
adapt for them,
they're asking for it
because you haven't adapted
well enough for them
for the new context
that they already
find themselves in.
It's not about the
backward-looking scenario.
It's about the
forward-looking scenario
where you're not already ahead.
And the argument behind the
extensible web manifesto
is that you're not
going to be ahead.
I can't predict the future.
And I know that you're probably
better than me at this.
But I also have a
reason to doubt.
MIKE SHAVER: Thank you.
We move on to the
next question here
sort of in the similar vein.
A lot of the hardest
things to do smoothly
involve tracking the human input
where that feedback cycle needs
to be very, very tight.
And going through our
current abstractions
can be a big problem.
What are the missing
declarative or shortcut pieces
that would get us,
in shorter order,
to really a responsive and
smooth layout while resolving
some of these bigger issues?
Maybe what would you
Charles-- what would you
like to see as a way to just
say, track this or give me
fast feedback on this
for the kinds of apps
you're building at Flipboard?
CHARLES YING: I'll say
that a lot of what we've
done in the past to make
performance, even on native,
track well with good latency has
been to rasterize things, shove
them in images, and then
show these images as facades,
and let the user
interact with them.
Browsers do that by rendering
web content into tiled images,
and then show the
users the images.
If we had more control to
be able to render content
and control how those
[INAUDIBLE] to the user,
we could give a lot more
smoothness to the user
without saying to
the browsers, we
need every little ounce of
performance you can give us.
We can fake things.
We have the ability
to fake things.
We can put Band-aids
around things.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm just curious.
How does that differ from,
say, having a canvas where
you can rasterize and take
control of rasterization
yourself?
CHARLES YING: So
on Flipboard, we
have this page flip animation
where we cut the page in half
and we flip it down like this.
So the way we do that is
we render the entire page
into an image, and then we split
it apart in the scene graph
on the native side.
And yes, I could
re-implement CSS in HTML,
and render everything in it.
That's been done before.
But it's not ideal.
So what we actually do
is we clone the node,
and we animate the two
halves in two different DOMs.
That's also really scary, too.
PAUL LEWIS: I guess
the reason I'm asking
is because if you
were so inclined,
you could take WebGL
and 3GS, and and you
could have a scene
graph, and you
could check out an
image as a texture,
and have it do the 3D thing--
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: But you've
got to reimplement everything
if you do that.
CHARLES YING: But we've got
all text rendering and all text
layout as well.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU:
[INAUDIBLE].
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
So you see one of the goodies
of the ease of doing the web
thing without having
to reimplement-- OK.
MIKE SHAVER: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: Right.
Fine.
CHRISTOPHER CHEDEAU: And
we had this with front-side
[INAUDIBLE] where
unfortunately Chrome is not
guaranteeing that it's
going to be in the layer.
So we have no guarantee
that everything
that's going to be
inside of this animation
is not going to blow up
and re-layout while you're
doing anything,
which is very scary.
MIKE SHAVER: We have from
the audience here Dominic.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So speaking to this question
in particular about,
like, touch and easy
shortcuts that we can do,
I think this is really
interesting, because there's
competing instincts people
have on the browser side.
Some of them are like, we
should make touch events really
low level, and we should
give you, like, hooks
into before scroll
that are synchronous.
And then you can-- if
you're really careful
and you code really
well, you can
get 60 FPS and complete control.
Whereas some of the
other ideas that I think
are really, really interesting,
and I want to see more of
are what if we made gestures
or scrolling a timing,
like a timeline that you could
hook up into web animations.
So you could say, I
want this animation
to be controlled by how
the user is scrolling
or how they're gesturing.
And that to me, when
you think of shortcuts
that would make these
things easier and also fast,
that, I think, is one of
the most interesting ideas
I've seen.
I'm not really sure
if people are into it.
But I wanted to put
it out there in case
people hadn't heard of it.
DAVID BARON: I think the thing
to connect animation timelines
to scrolling is a good idea.
There's proposals for
it for both, I think,
web animations and
for CSS animations.
And I think a lot of people
are pretty excited about that.
MIKE SHAVER: Yeah.
Looking at some of the
web VR stuff that's
being mooted right now,
one of the big issues in VR
is the very low latency between
motion-to-photon to avoid
sim sickness and so forth.
If that's something we can
do in a programmatic way,
that's great.
Are there going
to be cases where
we need to punch through
those abstractions for really
purpose-built stuff?
PAUL LEWIS: We have a history of
punching through for scrolling.
And it's great
for that use case.
But the moment you step off
that path, you're in trouble.
You're in a lot of problem.
And there's no way back out.
When somebody says,
shortcut, it's
like, for me, the
caveat has to be
but it's a recreateable
shortcut with underpinning--
MIKE SHAVER: And with
a smooth gradient
of performance, ideally,
rather than some discontinuity.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Otherwise, it's
just unreasonable,
because it's magic again.
MIKE SHAVER: Right.
Tobias is-- yeah, if you
have something to add,
and I hope lots of people do,
if you raise your hand when
you add yourself
to the list, then
we can get the microphone
to you early and so forth.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So sorry, it's not related
to that question now.
So regarding your fast path
in the browser where you say,
well, I want to limit
myself to, let's
say Flexbox or
something, because I know
the brower's faster
there, how about we
give the user control
of searching this?
And whenever you use something
else, it gives you an error.
Then you couldn't
even use it, and you
would know if there's
something that
would trigger the slow path.
What's the problem with that?
WILSON PAGE: Could you repeat?
I didn't really
get the last of--
MIKE SHAVER: You mean to
provide sort of a strict mode
that pages can opt into a
smaller surface of the web
platform--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
MIKE SHAVER: And
they just error out
if they touch the wrong things?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Right.
WILSON PAGE: That sounds
like a good idea to me,
but David said, like, vendors
can already kind of predict
what features you're going to
be using by just seeing what
properties you're--
DAVID BARON: It's not
that we can predict.
But if there's some
great thing we can do,
we could already just count
whether you're doing it or not,
and optimize based on that.
The point he's making
is that he wants
to ensure that he doesn't
fall off that fast path.
We could do that sort of thing.
When you say, error, people
have different interpretations
of error.
I think we don't want the
yellow screen of death,
for those of you who are
familiar with external parse
errors.
But we could take a
root where you opt in
to having a feature not work,
where "not work" means silently
fail in some way.
PAUL LEWIS: Wouldn't that
ruin the debug aspects
where you go, I think
this should work,
but again, it magically
doesn't work now?
Or it feels like it--
because maybe you
include a web component that
had switched something off
or didn't expect something.
Like that idea that
you're not always--
MIKE SHAVER: [INAUDIBLE]
transitive knowledge.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
You're not always in control
of every part of the page.
And if that feels like it
would work in the context
where you are, that
would be a concern
that, yes, you don't
have the final say.
Or if you switch
something on, you say,
don't ever switch this off.
And something that you need
to use needs to switch it off,
we're in a very horrible place.
WILSON PAGE: Yeah,
that doesn't really
work when you're using
third-party scripts and stuff.
You have no idea what
APIs they're using.
And you might be like, oh,
I don't need an [INAUDIBLE],
and turn it off.
And then--
MIKE SHAVER: Well, it's
a manifest-- no, sorry,
I don't want to bore that talk.
Sorry.
I actually want to skip
a couple questions,
because we only have time
for one more, I think.
And I want to go
back to something
Dominic raised earlier, which
is that native toolkits provide
a ton of help for doing smooth
layout and smooth interactions.
What do we need to
borrow from that?
And where is the web
just-- where can we just
copy our way to victory
in some of these cases?
On support side, you deal
with a bunch of native pieces
and you deal with a
bunch of web stuff.
What do you miss most in terms
of the performance and layout
characteristics when you
come back to the web?
CHARLES YING: I
think for us, most,
we probably miss improved
text manipulation primitives.
I mean, more
broadly, I would say
that things that are
missing are a pure way
to get to render things into
a texture and show that.
We know that this has
security implications
if I were to render the
bank header in the browser
Chrome on the screen.
But having that kind
of behavior allows
us to improve a lot of
paths in the application.
And just more generally,
at previous companies,
we've adopted Flash-like scene
graphs with shaders and things
that run very fast, attached
to the hardware very closely,
and having something
like core animation,
or some other type
of scene graph
would help with a lot
of animation cases
that we run into.
MIKE SHAVER: And so I mean,
you, on the Firefox OS
side, Wilson-- I mean, you're
trying to build stuff that's
experientially competitive with
those other platforms, right?
You're really going
head to head with them.
What us hard for you there?
What do you go and stand over
David's desk and bang on it
for?
WILSON PAGE: I don't know.
Well, at the moment,
like, tooling.
We just need tooling.
We need to know where
we're spending time.
And there's always
this, like, pressure
to no regression,
starter time must
be as fast as
possible, blah, blah.
But sometimes it's
tricky to know, yeah,
exactly what's happening.
Unless you're a gecko
expert, it's very hard
to know where exactly
I'm spending my time
and how I should be laying
out the page differently.
So there's a few
people at Mozilla
who know rendering
really, really well.
And they can just look
at the display lists
and just say, oh,
yeah, clearly, using
this element looks
a bit strange to me,
and a list of 1,000 elements.
And I'd really like
just more tooling
to surface these faux pas
to make things easier.
PAUL LEWIS: When
I look at this, I
think things like
Polymer web components
hopefully helps there where
accepted good ways to do
things can start to be
shared with other people.
So if somebody makes a
phenomenal infinite scrolling
list, that that could be shared,
that that can be built upon,
and that that includes,
baked into it,
the fast path, the
idea of how you
should do these
kinds of things so
that if you want to do your
own thing, you still can,
because that fast
path-- and maybe we
need to build down
a bit, like we're
saying with these extra hooks,
to do those really well.
But you've got it in
both directions now.
You've got a kind of example
that you can take and hopefully
configure.
And you've got also
the underlying ways
of re-doing that thing
yourself rather than
kind of hoping that
you can recreate it.
I think that's what we need.
And hopefully, that
fast-tracks a lot
of people who are-- they're
like, I need to make a web app.
It's gotta have these features.
Why don't I just
use that thing that
is already shipped and good?
WILSON PAGE: Yeah.
That's the most
exciting thing for me,
that we can actually start
sharing these pieces.
And someone who doesn't know
that much about performance
and all the things
you need to know
to get a well-performing app can
just take a piece off the shelf
and just use it, and
then suddenly they've
got something that's
performing as well as native.
And that's something the
web's never had before.
Yeah, you could maybe if you
were using the same library
as someone else, you
might be able to use
a component that they built.
But the fact that we have
it built into the platform
now is super exciting.
And I think for
us in Firefox OS,
we're really going to see--
we're banking on web components
to really accelerate
the number of apps that
are going to land
in the marketplace.
If we can just give
developers a package
and just say, look, here you go,
you can build an app in a day.
To get that.
And that's something that
I think we're going really,
really start.
MIKE SHAVER: You
raised the issue, too,
of not needing to have
a lot of expertise
in order to make a
high-performance web app.
But I think you're on iOS.
You need to work relatively hard
to make something that's janky.
So it feels like
we're really kind
of at the wrong
ends of that there.
We're at the end of our
time as well, unfortunately.
So I do want to thank the
panel and everybody that
contributed to this.
I think layout
performance is an area
we need to see a lot of
attention to in the future
if we're going to take
web apps to the next area.
So thanks all a lot
for your participation.
[APPLAUSE]